demain au tribunal de troyes
s'ouvrira le procès de patrick henry
présumé coupable de l'assassinât d'un
enfant qui l'aurait enlevée qui l'avait
enlevée pour de l'argent comme le
rappelle certains confrères aujourd'hui
il y a eu en 76 ans 75 aussi un certain
nombre de meurtres d'enfants abominable
allez savoir pourquoi ces affaires n'ont
pas fait grand bruit le meurtre du petit
philippe bertrand à 3 à polariser la
colère et quelques autres sentiment de
l'opinion publique son impuissance à
comprendre comment un homme banal a pu
en arriver là est immense elle dépasse
toute logique pourtant il faudrait que
la sérénité puisse s'établir dans ce
tribunal de province avant de juger il
faut savoir et surtout refusé de dire je
ne veux pas savoir jean pierre berthet
suivra pour nous ce procès
au delà ou à travers patrick henry c'est
d'abord le principe même du procès qui
est en accusation dans une partie non
négligeable de l'opinion publique il y a
ceux qui réclament l exécution de
patrick henry le jour même de son
arrestation pour ces gens là les
tribunaux ont parfois d indulgence
coupable et il faut s'en méfier à
l'opposé il ya ceux qui dénoncent
l'hypocrisie d'un procès dont le verdict
la peine capitale serait à l'avance une
quasi certitude
en voilà qui ne crois pas une minute à
l'indépendance de conscience des juges
professionnels et des jurés populaires
paradoxalement le crime de patrick henry
aura donc réuni deux familles de
citoyens qui n'ont rien en commun si ce
n'est une confusion dramatique vengeance
et justice pense-t-il c'est pareil
la vérité est tout autre le besoin de
vengeance doit s'arrêter là où l'action
de la justice commence patrick henry
appartient à la catégorie des criminels
les plus odieux c'est indéniable
enlèvement et meurtre d'un enfant avec
demande de rançon aux malheureux parents
contre cet enchaînement de crime le code
pénal n'a pas prévu une mais deux fois
la peine de mort et pourtant demain
matin devant la cour d'assises de l'aube
il va falloir repartir de zéro et tenir
compte de la psychologie du passé de
l'accusé au moins autant que des faits
qui lui sont reprochés ne plus être
obsédé par le cynisme de patrick henry
souhaitant publiquement on s'en souvient
avant son arrestation la mort des
ravisseurs d'enfant ou ne plus être
influencé par l'empressement de trois
ministres a réclamé le châtiment suprême
en écho à l'indignation populaire
l'horreur du crime peut à la rigueur
excuser les excès de passion des
premiers jours mais demain il y a une
vertu qui doit être commune ceux qui
accusent et à ceux qui défendent la
dignité